Now that we've opened the Twinmotion,
we're gonna take a look at navigating around the scene.
So first when you open up, as we mentioned before,
you'll see this wonderful home screen.
However, if you close this out
after either selecting a template
or just running this default project,
which opens every time you first open Twinmotion.
So we'll take a look at everything through here
and how to navigate
as well as we'll be doing a few other things.
So let's take a look.
Now real briefly in the slides
that are available to you as mentioned before,
we can see that there are multiple ways
in which you can navigate.
Now we're gonna go inside Twinmotion
to take a look at that,
but here are just a few to get you started.
Now one of the other things I did want to mention
is on a different type of keyboard, the Ezerte keyboard.
As you can see, it uses the Z, Q, S, D keys
instead of the typical W, A, S, D keys.
Just keep that in mind.
We can also change the navigational presets
to whatever you're familiar with.
So you could change it to keep it the Twinmotion editor
or even Unreal editor,
or perhaps you use Modo or Cinema 4D in Maya.
And in any case, you can switch that
to be more like a navigational tools that you're used to.
I'm gonna stick with the Twinmotion editor for now.
And then also I wanted to show you the navigational panel,
which we'll look at here just in a second within there
to get an idea where things are at like speed
and what you're zooming and going through,
flying through your scene.
That does make a difference
when you're trying to focus in on some of those scenes.
So let's take a look inside of Twinmotion.
And as I said before, this is default project.
So this will get started to kind of see things we're at.
But as we progress through our course,
we're gonna take a look at another project
that is included, which is the Lake House project.
But as we can see here,
we did briefly go over the whole settings of the library
where everything is held,
as well as some of the other things here with the scene,
the ambiance where you can change even the sun,
which if you just go like that, yep,
you can totally change and blow it out
or make it completely dark.
Either way, whatever you choose, this is the way to do that.
We can even go from other things like appearances,
we can select the intensity,
some of the other settings, location.
Yes, you can even select where it's at on a map.
So let's say you wanted to build something
in the middle of Paris, good old Paris,
you could do that by simply locating it in here.
And it will actually give you the time and day
based on what is in that area.
So very great.
And you do have a lot of different ways of selecting
even the type of the month, when it's at,
right now we're set on default by June,
but you could set it all the way into December
to make it look more like it would for winter.
But another great setting available to you.
Now navigational, one of the first ones
I always like to discuss is the F as in Frank.
If you select an object, let's say like the sphere
and you hit F, you'll notice it zooms right in.
Now that's pretty typical for most DCC programs,
but it really works really well for us here.
Now some of the other things, the zoom wheel,
as you can see the mouse, if you zoom in and out,
it does exactly what you say, the zooming.
And then we have the control button, control C,
which we try to do that will rotate around that object.
Now, if you were just to do control,
it would do the same thing.
So we can do that as well.
Now, if you do the right mouse button, as it shows,
you'll see your camera is actually painting,
let's say like on a tripod versus control,
where it goes around the object that is selected.
So let's say that you selected something off,
you'll notice it's rotating around whatever the center,
what it was we selected.
So again, if you select like the base, for example,
right here, and you were to rotate,
you'll notice it does rotate or pivot around.
So again, that, and then alt,
it's gonna give you a slightly different pivot
and control with the right mouse button, right?
So those both give you that nice little pivot
around a tripod.
So just keep that in mind.
That's a few things that we have available to us.
And I did wanna mention a few things over here.
If you click on this,
it actually will bounce off into your other screen,
but it makes it full screen.
Now this is important later lessons
that you're gonna take.
This opens up some other features.
So I'm gonna turn that off and just go ahead
and select this little picture here, the eye.
This gives you the settings for what you need.
Like this is the time of day,
and you could actually change the time of day
just by simple lever, really cool.
And you'll notice that even the sun changes its position.
And then I wanna click here.
This is the speed I was talking about earlier.
Right now it's set to cycle speed,
which is, this is what you see for zooming.
Now that's great if you're in middle detail kind of set.
If you're looking at a really large area,
you may wanna do it to fly speed six.
And the reason I say that is you wanna get in
and out really quickly.
Now again, you can set this to something even slower,
let's say to an inspect speed.
This is great for really, really detailed.
But as you saw, it goes very slowly,
but see when you're up close, that may be what you want.
Now you can also, if you notice,
press the number button in order to control that,
you'll see the little number.
So if you press one through six,
so we can press six, you'll notice it goes to six.
If we go to one, it's super slow, okay?
I'm gonna set it to four,
which is what it was on by default.
That's pretty good.
And we'll go through here a little bit more.
We have this little camera icon,
which takes a screenshot just as its name implies.
You'll see some other settings
and we're not gonna go into too much more of these.
These are a little bit more advanced settings.
However, if you click on here, you can show navigation.
Now for those that are just starting,
this is really great,
cause it lets you see what we're needing to do, right?
And there's the speed as mentioned,
and you can even use the AWSD keys
and the QE for up and down.
So like if I were to hit Q and E,
you'll see that does it really quickly, right?
So again, most of these are gonna be for more advanced,
that's your VR and we'll discuss that
in a much later course,
as well as some of the other features here.
Now this will be it for our navigational.
So what we're gonna do next
is we're gonna actually add an asset
into our lake house scene.
So go ahead and close the scene when you're ready
and open up the lake house project that was provided.
Okay, see you shortly.